[Musica]
sì è una bottiglia di plastica
mi dà fastidio
potete dirlo servita fastidio non mi
offendo
potete dirlo che mi sarei dovuta portare
una di quelle borracce che fanno tanto
adesso colorate
allora aspettate che la vado a prendere
ecco ora sì che siamo green no
funziona così anno
fatevi sentire per alzata di mano
quanti di voi sono attenti al consumo
della plastica
tanti
quanti di voi riciclano
tantissimi
quanti di voi hanno tagliato la carne
dalla propria dieta
può più timidi
adesso vi faccio un ultima domanda
quanti di voi sentono di fare davvero la
differenza
sapete
ci hanno ingannati per decenni hanno
fatto passare il messaggio che
l'inquinamento e riscaldamento globale
fossero una responsabilità individuale e
che quindi anche le soluzioni dovessero
essere responsabilità individuale chi ci
ha ingannati di chi sto parlando
delle aziende di gas petrolio e carbone
delle aziende di combustibili fossili
ma non solo
visto confondendo
facciamo un passo indietro
questo è uno spot pubblicitario degli
anni 70 il cui slogan recitava le
persone inquinano le persone possono
fermare l'inquinamento
faceva parte di una campagna
pubblicitaria ideata da chi era
un'organizzazione fondata da aziende
leader nel settore di packaging e
bevande fermamente contrarie due nazioni
ambientalista questa campagna
pubblicitaria cambio all'america
introdusse l'idea della instabilità
individuale l'obiettivo era distogliere
l'attenzione dalle industrie della
produzione in modo tale che potessero
continuare ad agire indisturbate e
questa strategia ha avuto successo
avete presente impronta è
il concetto di impronta di carbonio
quante volte ne avrete sentito parlare
come ridurre la propria impronta di
carbonio dieci passi per ridurre la
propria impronta ecologica
ecco sapevate che il concetto di
impronta di carbonio è stato promosso da
un'azienda di petrolio
nel 2004 l'azienda presenta un
calcolatore per misurare le impronte di
carbone individuale il contributo di
emissioni un'idea vincente le
piattaforme mediatiche fecero propria
l'espressione nel giro di pochi anni e
la responsabilità individuale diventa un
tormentone
la stampa dava consigli su come fare per
ridurre all'impronta di carbonio in
molti si davano da fare
questa di per sé non è una cosa negativa
peccato che nel frattempo le industrie
la macchina negazionista hanno
continuato ad evadere la responsabilità
ea mantenere loro business as usual il
capovolgimento operato dai negazionisti
è stato efficace
questa è solo una parte della storia
purtroppo non ho il tempo di
raccontarvela tutta ma vi dirò questo la
macchina negazionista le aziende di
combustibili fossili tintin conservatori
le lobby gli scienziati negazionisti
finanziati delle lobby alcune
piattaforme mediatiche perfino alcuni
politici hanno messo in atto una vera e
propria campagna di disinformazione sul
clima durata decenni che è stata
estremamente efficace
sapete chi sono state tra le prime a
osservare il collegamento tra l'attività
di bruciare combustibili fossili
l'aumento delle emissioni il conseguente
aumento della temperatura
le aziende di gas petrolio il carbone
avevano scienziati preparatissimi che
già dagli anni 70 avevano osservato
questo legame e avevano fatto previsioni
estremamente accurate sulle conseguenze
di continuare con questa attività
ma poi le aziende cosa hanno fatto
hanno nascosto tutto
abbiamo documenti dati tutto
secondo i promemoria interni che
risalgono agli anni 80 una delle
maggiori aziende statunitensi di
combustibili fossili aveva previsto
scenari dagli effetti catastrofici
senza contare che più della metà delle
emissioni industriali di nitride
carbonica sono stati prodotti dopo che
gli scienziati di queste aziende avevano
dato l'allarme
ora pensate
se i negazionisti avessero agito
diversamente
se i negazionisti avessero cambiato
rotta dove saremmo oggi
dove potremmo essere
certo non è tutto così bianco e nero ma
la verità è che i negazionisti ci hanno
ingannato e si tratta di danni di
dimensioni incalcolabili se prendiamo in
considerazione la perdita di vite a
causa della crisi climatica le
alterazioni climatiche i loro effetti la
perdita di biodiversità lo scioglimento
dei ghiacci l'innalzamento del livello
del mare e qui l'elenco potrebbe
continuare davvero molto a lungo
la responsabilità della crisi climatica
non è condivisa da tutti ugualmente
forse qualcuno dirà ma che importa di
chi è la colpa
importa importa perché se non capiamo
come siamo arrivati fin qui andare
avanti in maniera diversa sarà molto
difficile lottare per l'ambiente per il
clima sarà molto difficile lottare per
noi stessi sarà molto difficile
che poi
cos'è l'ambiente
la parola ambiente sotto intende sempre
l'ambiente dell'essere umano ma non
siamo noi stessi parte di quell ambiente
che continuiamo a considerare separato
dall'uomo non siamo noi stessi noi
sapiens parte integrante degli
ecosistemi della biosfera
il filosofo tre matrimoni tra la spiega
così
se cominci a pensare alla biosfera come
una testa che sogna ti accorgerai che
tutto all'interno di quella biosfera è
sintomo ed espressione della biosfera
stessa non c'è un fuori
questo significa essere ecologicamente
consapevoli
è chiaro che qualcosa finora non ha
funzionato
qualcosa è andato storto
la separazione dalla natura alimentata
da quello che viene chiamato dualismo ha
promosso l'idea che la terra sia nostre
che possiamo farne ciò che vogliamo che
possiamo distruggere
colonizzare sfruttare senza
ripercussioni che possiamo possedere
ecco che la terra sia nostra e la
possediamo è un'illusione
e prima ci facciamo i conti prima saremo
in grado
di inaugurare una vita nòva
quindi cosa fare davvero le azioni
individuali non contano
assolutamente no tutto quello che a
livello individuale si può fare per
attenuare la crisi climatica è
fondamentale ma le azioni individuali da
sole non ci salveranno e dico ci perché
la terra non ha bisogno di noi per
essere salvata
quello che ci salverà è un'azione
politica coraggiosa e necessaria è il
disinvestimento dai fossile o
decarbonizzazione e abbandonare
l'ossessione capitalista per la crescita
e il dualismo
inaugurare una nuova dimensione quello
in cui riconosciamo che noi siamo parte
integrante degli ecosistemi non li
governiamo non li dominiamo e non li
possediamo
per farlo non dobbiamo abbandonare la
civiltà
non credete a chi vi dice che
chi vuole tutto questo va contro il
progresso la civiltà la tecnologia non
credete a chi non vuole volgere lo
sguardo in avanti per paura di perdere
potere oggi non credete a chi ha
beneficiato di una cultura dominante
delle terre ea a chi ha imposto i propri
valori e le proprie regole a scapito di
tutti gli altri
l'egemonia culturale di cui parlava
antonio gramsci che dobbiamo scardinare
e farlo a livello individuale è
impossibile il corto circuito e
sistemico
credere che il sistema che ha prodotto
la crisi sia lo stesso che può
occuparsene è una trappola
nel 1995 dopo che furono sterminati i
lupi furono reintrodotti nel parco
nazionale di yellowstone negli stati
uniti nel giro di pochi anni gli alberi
ricominciarono a crescere perché i
terreni non erano più così sopra
pascolati dai cervi
offrivano rifugio a molte spese
addirittura stabilizzarono i corsi
d'acqua
perchè il tasso di erosione diminuì e si
crearono stagni e secche
queste in termini tecnici e un processo
che si chiama cascata trofica ma in
realtà
una storia che è un esempio tangibile di
cosa significa vivere all'interno di un
sistema complesso come la biosfera dove
tutte cause conseguenza dell'altro e che
non esiste solo come insieme di specie e
luoghi fisici ma come interazione tra
ciascuna specie l'habitat naturale
ecco l'ecologia è questo l'interazione
tra gli esseri viventi e l'ecosistema
ed è per questo che l'ecologia non ha
solo a che fare con l'ambiente con il
clima ma con tutto ciò che ci riguarda
dalla salute pubblica alle questioni
sociali dall'economia alla politica
dalla cultura alla giustizia
immaginare un nuovo paradigma dove c'è
una comprensione profonda di queste
interazioni e dove l'emergenza climatica
viene affrontata come crisi che
interseca tutte le crisi è possibile e
anche agire per metterlo in atto lo è
siamo ancora in tempo
possiamo ancora cambiare le cose ma
dobbiamo agire subito e informarsi
sensibilizzare riconoscere i meccanismi
tossici del nostro sistema è
fondamentale per cambiare rotta solo
così possiamo sottrarci al negazionismo
alla manipolazione all'inganno
vorrei tornare ora alla filosofia di
timo filmato
l'ecologia non è solo qualcosa che ha
che fare con il riscaldamento globale il
riciclaggio e l'energia solare a che
fare con l'amore la perdita la
disperazione e la compassione a che fare
con la depressione la psicosi con lo
stupore l'apertura mentale la meraviglia
ecologia scoprire in ogni cosa lo
stupore la mia miglia e allo stesso
tempo fare di tutto di tutto per
combattere la perdita
[Applauso]